that's terrible all right more
Republicans lining up for the chance to
send Joe Biden into retirement Senator
Tim Scott declaring his candidacy and
taking aim at liberal ideology
Joe Biden and the radical left are
attacking every single rung of the
ladder that helped me climb victimhood
or victory
grievance or greatness
I choose freedom and hope and
opportunity
will you choose it with me and the
ladies of the view aren't too happy with
Tim Scott and are discounting his
candidacy because they think Republicans
are racist
he came out and did that dog whistle
victimhood as soon as you say that you
know what he's talking about I didn't
like that he seems to think because I
made it everyone can make it ignoring
again the fact that he is the exception
and not the rule and until he is the
rule then he can stop talking about
systems
God what an inner circle of hell that is
the fact that that if the judge the fact
that you say don't be a victim you know
being is somehow a dog whistle for
racism and that success is the exception
and not the rule that's what they said
and and they are not white women there
they've been very sexy so they are the
exceptions what have they been doing for
the past 40 years yeah but the truth is
everything that's being said now is not
about reality it's not about truth
anymore it's all about party okay if
they didn't have a political letter on
them they could have been they could
have been supporting him and saying look
to the African-American community you
can come literally From Slavery and be a
United States Senator run for president
they're so hateful I've never seen a
group so hateful as the group on The
View and they say the Republican party
is rarely diverse well wait a minute
we've got Vivek ramaswamy running for
president we've got Nikki Haley running
for president we got Tim Scott running
for president who do you have an old guy
and everyone's afraid to run against him
an old white guy yeah yeah on top of
that they're propping up an old white
guy and calling them Republicans racists
and I guess they assume that Vivek and
Tim Scott are all the new faces of white
supremacy exactly what did they say
about the lieutenant governor of uh
Virginia that she was a was it a black
mouthpiece for white nationalism or
something like that you can't win you
can't win with them I I you know I Tim
is a good friend I really like him and I
I wish him very well as he pursues this
but speaking about the Democrats and the
DNC if you listen to them there is no
primary there is no opposition they're
going to try to pretend Bobby kenned
he's not pulling at 20 percent because
they don't want to have to put Joe Biden
on the record to compare and contrast
hey you have a record the American
people Democrat voters actually do have
a choice in this election and uh you
know they're going to try to ignore him
for as long as they can because they're
deathly afraid of him and they're going
to do to him what they did to me in the
Democratic primary of 2020 which is
pretend you don't exist and then if you
start people start noticing you then
they will try to smear and cancel and
destroy him at all costs I remember what
Hillary did to you exactly yeah and
she's still standing in faceless smears
that get that repeated over and over and
over again by the propaganda media until
people actually start to believe it and
it starts causing some real death but on
the bright side Hillary didn't kill you
body double right now
exactly
Jesse uh you we were in the break
talking about Tim Scott and how excited
you are and what a positive powerful
message he has as an unmarried 57 year
old man who could devote all of his time
to the office and not be bothered by the
annoyances it but pesky children and
annoying spouses you mean when I was
telling you that I was now off the Trump
train yeah now on the Tim Scott train
yes that's a true shoe with all due
respect I don't understand that Tim
Scott thing uh nice guy but nice guys
finish last to me he's just your average
Republican senator he votes with
Republicans and that's a good thing but
he's got a good personal story and then
the personal story kind of stops and you
don't know anything else about his
personal story you have a terrible
personal story I'm just getting started
this guy is not running for president
he's running for cabinet and people do
that you run for a cabinet position or
you run for VP I don't know is Trump
flirting with the guy he was saying nice
things about Scott's going to say nice
things about him but Scott's got no shot
he'll probably get fleeced by his
Consultants or other Consultants will
just say Republicans aren't racist
because Tim Scott's running for
president I don't really care about what
color Tim Scott's skin is and I'm sick
of everyone talking about what color his
skin is every time you hear him covered
on the mainstream media it's about his
skin on conservative meeting it's about
his skin I don't want to talk about his
skin I want to talk about the country
could we just talk about the country
let's talk about his muscles
what have you seen him with a shirt off
he's a great shape is he really he's in
great shape I think the problem here
Jesse's very cynical he believes that
the only people the only people who
should run for office are the ones who
have it in the bag so you just want like
you just want I don't even think he's a
long shot let's put it that way let's
see wow you know what do you think he
has a shot at being the president if you
have DeSantis and Trump in the primary
do you know go ahead what bothers me
Dana is that he does have a positive and
Powerful message overcoming obstacles
championing uh individual Freedom he's
not a victim and yet all of that can be
discounted as he's just a dog whistle of
white supremacy it's like now when you
talk about success that is supposed to
be like an insult to black people how
did that happen one of the things that
is impressive about him is how he lets
that roll off his back you remember he
was the one who was trying to put
forward police reform and all the
Democrats turned on him and they could
have actually had that accomplishment if
they had wanted it it was right there
for the taking uh he is up he's well
liked he's got friends all across around
the Senate he's optimistic he has also
helped build the party not just by being
who he is but putting his money where
his mouth is he has raised a ton of
funding for uh for people who are
running in Republican races all across
the country and and so he really
believes what he says now in any other
race in any other primary this might
have been a trajectory changing thing in
the race but because the media just
wants to focus on his color of his skin
and the fact that he has 22 million
dollars they'll say something positive
about him maybe but president Trump also
said things that are nice about him the
media and president Trump are going
after DeSantis and that announcement is
happening this week that's where the
story I think lies right now all right
well Senator Tim Scott will join Trey
Gowdy on Fox News tonight at 8 pm
Eastern that's Tim Scott
of course it's shredding lockdown
liberals who trampled all over our civil
liberties hi welcome
to braid I want you to
do X News YouTube
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now